space is continuous there's no shortest
distance in space you get to the end of
the 19th century and uh people were
discovering Quantum Mechanics for
example people were wondering whether
molecules existed well that didn't get
resolved until the first decade of the
20th century then Einstein in 1905
basically said well light is discret as
well it has photons and so then next
thing was discret so the next question
was is space discrete and actually I've
been finding more and more that at that
time for the first 20 30 years of the
20th century the typical physicists
believed space was discreet you know
back I think 1916 for example Einstein
had a nice little quote that said in the
end space will turn out to be discreet
but we don't have the tools we need to
study that yet so 100 years later we do